thank you
there you go
it's um they're not going to be here
next time around in fact while three we
know of there may well be others but
that'll come in due course I guess but
certainly the
the the time and the commitment that has
been put into this Council by those
three retiring members I believe
deserve a recognition and we have
councilor Doug Grant
um who was elected in 2012 and has
served 10 years we've got Council Nikki
Davis who was elected in 2001 and served
21 years and councilor Cliff Bulger who
was elected in 1998 and has served 24
years so altogether 55 years of service
is effectively ending tonight
and certainly from my perspective as Mia
I just want to say thank you thank you
to the three of you for the contribution
that you have made
um I was going to say you've made my
life easier but certainly you've made
made my life interesting for the last 19
years and most of it's been really
really good so so thank you for that
I've I've valued the contribution you've
made I've valued the friendship that
we've had around the table
and personally I wish you all the very
best for whatever the next stage is in
each of your particular Journeys and and
I know that the
had the
the schools and the experience that you
have gathered around this table will
count very highly I believe in whatever
choice you make in terms of your
um your business and and your personal
activities going forward but just as a
as a a recognition of that service I've
just got some certificates and a couple
of other mementos I would like to award
to those counselors at this particular
time
so um if I could ask each of them to
come forward as the is their name is is
called
first up we do have councilor Doug grant
for 2012 to 2022.
Doug if you'd like to come forward
[Applause]
welcome to Mike
thank you Jesse thanks very much
10 years ago
um actually it was longer
2010 I was approached by Tracy himself
and to ask to stand for the council at
the time
we air business where we're going
through a refit Paper Plus
so is it no couldn't do it in 2012 a
by-election turned up and um again he
pissed at me you probably wished he
hadn't later on
but no honestly um it's been a pleasure
I've had
10 years of sitting around the table a
lot of learning a lot of
boardroom type decisions
we do a lot of interaction
with the public and that's one of the
biggest things that a counselor can do
my uh I was elected in March on a
Saturday my first interaction was on a
Tuesday
the little old man came into the shop he
said oh you're that new councilor fella
aren't you I said yes I am
right got a problem
so out we go outside and here's a
leaking veranda
further along Oak Street where Peter
Cairns had his music shop been leaking
for quite some time and I've noticed it
but
it's not my shop we'd fix theirs his was
leaking anyway this guy said what are
you going to do about it
this was on the Tuesday
and I thought well I don't know don't
really know a lot about how Council
works so a bit of weight till I see
Tracy or have a meeting or whatever
I I walked to work and on Thursday
morning
um
Jones and Cooper had scaffolding up it
was just absolute perfect timing that
the landlord decided to fix it the wee
man came back in on Friday
avoid Mr grad you're a good counselor
so that was my first win it was and
that's the way it's sort of been but you
know you get your wins you get your
losses we've seen some things we got a
hiding with with
Streets Alive it was sort of handed down
to us you know something that was pushed
on us but uh we did the best we could we
did get a hiding on it
we've had some different differences so
different differences tricy and myself
I've met I reached and that but you know
we got there in the end it was the right
timing you know we got there in the end
it's been a great Council to work with
just two thankful thanks I would like to
thank firstly my wife Denise
she has put up with a lot of
um
me being being away from the shop and
that but also she won't come shopping
with me because every time I go shopping
to new world it's better here and 20
minutes to get out you get just get
asked questions and stuff which is fine
the second uh the
my staff and the shop they've put up
with a lot for being away
from from a business
but um just just for those and also I'd
like to thank the councilors sitting
around this table
uh and then the past counselors that
have had the
uh to sit down here has been fantastic
um
you know
um local body I think local body
politics are days are numbered
personally I think there's a lot of
stuff coming out of central government
and who knows where it's going to go but
hopefully you know just last week or two
weeks ago I had a phone call from a lady
and she had an issue
it's my pocket ring don't worry about
the old Shell literal
anyway
um
she had an issue with a plumbing job on
her street so I the first thing I did
was I contacted Matt Bayless and I said
Matt we've got an issue and he said no
worries what's your address fixed it
and I think that's the sort of thing
that we're going to really really miss
if we go down the track we're looking at
um
my last comment there's three types of
people that sit around this table
there's those that make it happen those
that watch what happened and those that
wondered what happened hmm so please
anyone coming into the council just make
sure you're one of those
eyes that make it happen
thank you
thank you Doug
[Applause]
well done
um
okay so um councilor Nikki Davis well
before we do that is there any other
counselors that would like to make any
any feedback any comment what's relation
to Doug I thought there might be
um Brit
few things Tracy it might surprise
you've got something to say but Doug
you're actually the council that changed
the political will of this Council to
secure a material Valley milk for this
town the territory milk we're kicking
the can Brown this Council years and
years and then it started becoming a
reality and they started looking
elsewhere so you're the guy that got the
call and you brought the councils
together so I think you can put that on
your list of things that you did so
um certainly appreciate that and I'm
sure the township of Gore appreciates
that as well
um all the best I'm we're really
concerned that you're going to be pretty
lonely in this truck you like talking to
people I've heard
um so we've sort of sort of a way that
you might keep your company so
um Tom hence on Castaway
had Wilson so
all the way stag enjoy don't lose them
well done
um thank you Brit
um
councilor Nikki Davis Nikki
began her term on Council in 2001
and the mirror at the time was Owen
O'Connor and so a new mayor and a new
counselor and and worked really well
together and it was a good counsel by
all accounts that made quite a lot of
difference to the way that this
particular organization runs
so I know that in 2004 I was elected
mayor and
at that time I needed to there was a
number of changes around the table
um but I wanted to put my mark on the
way the council was organized and the
way the council ran
and I needed to sort out who were going
to be my cheers
and one of the chairs that I chose was
Nikki Davis and and Nikki I'll say to
you now and I think I've probably said
to you in the past I had a couple of
people that were not happy about that
decision at all but from my perspective
that was one of the better decisions
that I've made and and I've never ever
lived to regret that you've been a
council that has been absolutely
committed does the research does
understands the detail and has been
committed all the way through so thank
you very much for the contribution that
you have made
and it is a long one you know 21 years
we should have given you the key to the
door or key to the city or whatever that
is
um but I don't have a key to the city I
do have a certificate and I'd like to
ask you to come forward at this point in
time
so um
place
I've also I understand that John Nikki
do a lot of walking
around the
Point around the region so there's a guy
here to kicks on short walks
[Applause]
foreign
I just want to open by honoring some
former counselors who sadly have passed
and these counselors had an impact on me
on my first term on Council and they
impacted me one way or another so just
want us to honor them
so please let us remember counselors
bildor
Neil Harvey
Fred Sutherland
Alistair McLennan
Cyril McFadden and Mervin Harrier and
lastly and most important to note not
deceased so these aren't he's still with
us Ralph Beal Geoffrey Cunningham and of
course Cliff Bulger who's stepping down
this year too after a 24-year
contribution
these councilors and many others have
made a significant contribution to the
council and the community in their time
fit in if you wanted to speak and Amir
O'Connor you had to stand and
address the mere fellow councilors the
public and the reporters
under the rules you could only speak
once so if you moved to motion you could
you could speak at the end but if you
were commenting on emotion you could
only speak once so if you're moving
emotion you had to make it pretty
compelling and if you're Signet of it
you might have been lucky to get a
second go at speaking as well
the priests were always in attendance at
our meetings because we had quite a
turbulent first three years was very
very turbulent
the every move of council was reported
every single breath we took was just
about on the front page
the southern times and the enzyme were
often overflown with Council business
and headlines and what council was up to
and what we wound up to and what we
should be doing what we weren't doing so
it was a very very turbulent first three
years but I think we set the path for
Council after that because there were
just so many things that had needed to
be done
in my time on Council I've attended
hundreds of meetings and workshops
traveled to Wellington to meetings
attended Regional Zone meetings I can
attended conferences cheered the
operations committee for 15 years
and latterly wastenet and set on many
many hearing panels
when I was voted on to council my
daughter was five and her son was seven
and they came into the chambers with
John my husband to watch me be sworn in
and at the time my daughter's backpack
her school backpack was almost as big as
she was
21 years pass and here I am now having
come full circle with a brand new
granddaughter born in July this year
um that's quite quite a circle of life I
guess you could say
I'd like to thank my husband John who
often had to hold the fort in my
children for their unwavering support
and their encouragement too over the
last 21 years I couldn't underestimate
how much that meant and how much that
contributed to my being able to do my
role as a counselor
I'd just like to say in closing that the
opportunity given to you as a counselor
is by the people you represent the
people you think about the people with
every issue too
in every decision you think about the
people at the end of the day it is all
about them so thank you Tracy for the
opportunity to be a chairman I really
appreciated that and to everyone else I
wish you all the very very best in your
time ahead and hope you'll get back in
and I will sign off so thank you very
much
thank you
any other comments from any counselors
it's not I think 21 years speaks for
itself and and yeah well done making
from me
um that leaves us with councilor Cliff
Bulger
uh elected in 1998
um and 25 24 years
is a is a counselor almost a quarter of
a century
uh and
doesn't look a day older at all
and but one of the things I would have
to say that his mind has never stopped
in that that 24 years always looking for
an opportunity always looking for the
right way forward for this particular
Council
I've known Cliff for a long time well
before we were on on Council
I've known him as someone that is really
interested in the well-being of people
and the well-being of of this community
and to to have him on Council was a real
bonus for me in my first term as Amir
and Nikki's alluded to it and I'm
probably Cliff will talk about it too
the first term of that particular
Council was probably the only way to
describe it would be Hell on Wheels it
was it was one out of the box that you
would even if you read about it in
detail you probably wouldn't believe it
some of the goings-on that that happened
through those those three years but as a
as a group we stuck very very tight and
got to the end not knowing whether the
the public at large understood what was
going on because as Nikki said every day
in the southern times or the or the in
sign the headlines were raging about the
gore District Council and some
particular fashion or another
but
we all got to look to back so you you
know the public do see through some of
the the drama that is created and as we
go into the selection I guess we've just
got to remind ourselves that yep you do
what you do do the best you can and the
public will judge you on on what you're
doing
Cliff
was my Deputy for four terms and a
fantastic Deputy when he answered his
phone
um
uh absolutely brilliant when he answered
his phone
um I'd have to say but I couldn't have
wished for a better support than than
Cliff yeah and there were different
times that I needed that support uh he
was always there and he always had the
right words to say at the right time and
and I would have to say that in terms of
eloquence around the table Cliff doesn't
have any equals and hasn't had any
equals in in the the 19 years that that
I've been near he does it really really
well it's all like practicing talking on
the tractor I think a
it gets it out as out of the system and
gets himself into a logical context and
can do it really really well but thank
you Cliff for the contribution that you
have made
um you've been involved in some
interesting processes along the way and
some big consents you and Nikki and
Brett involved in that that first big
consent was trustpower which now was
only just starting to come to fruition
so those years later but
um so thank you for that that
contribution
again I've got a certificate here for
you and just a couple of other mementos
as well
one in particular I'm sure you'll
appreciate I know you like to stretch
your mind somewhat
and this one will stretch your mind but
firstly the certificate
[Applause]
I've got two other things here
so I don't know where this photo came
from but when I saw it I thought
um
foreign
Tracy and I have always enjoyed a little
bit of humor
off the ball so to speak thank you Tracy
firstly
uh
I'd like to think the right powers and
the voting rate pairs of District it's
been an absolute privilege and and I've
been humbled
to be a council for a counselor for this
length of time it has added so much
color experience
to my life that I otherwise would never
have had the chance to experience so
once again I'm very very grateful I'm
very thankful
um
I'll have to go back to the start
firstly
um
I was counselor with with
Mia OGG who took me under her wing and
then mayor O'Connor and then of course
for the last 19 years with yourself
Tracy
um
it's it's really been a jewel to be
enjoyable to be part of your Council
team and
[Music]
um
you know I have to honestly say uh on
the North you're doing magnificent job
and uh and I think the district is
fortunate I'd like to thank my fellow
councilors
um
I've enjoyed being part of a team with
you uh present and and previous and of
course staff
wonderful staff
um and in it's unfortunate probably The
Wider public don't realize what a robust
self-sacrificing group of individuals
serve in this organization and say thank
you Steve for the way you've learned it
so look once again
um
for those people of the district I think
you for the privilege of being your
counselor for the sleep of time thank
you
thank you Cliff is there any comments
anybody would like to make Brit and then
glennis
ladies first
thank you you worship I'd just like to
thank the retiring
counselors for the support when I first
came on Council
I sought a lot of advice and I'm really
truly grateful for that and their little
discussions Cliff I thank you very much
for those that I think we've enlightened
each other a little bit along the way
but um all the very best to the councils
who are retiring
thanks my address is to both cliff and
Nicki so I didn't speak before Nikki
because I wanted to address you both
together so I joined the council 15
years ago and it was a different time
even 15 years ago we squeezed around an
old Council table there's hardly enough
room drawers were banging on your knees
and the counselor I sat beside told me
that I was new and I should shut up and
listen for the first three years and I
wasn't qualified to comment so some
reason cliff and Nikki grabbed me and I
was mentored by them both and I think
they might have been worried I was this
young 38 year old guy just showed up
with a bit of interest and there was a
bit of an unrest in the community after
a group of counselors took off so we
wanted to have a peaceful time and and
really build a council that the
community respected and we served them
well so that was uh that was like I
appreciated all the time anything you
put into me
um and about 14 years ago as Tracy
mentioned we're a Commissioners on the
Colorado Downs Wind Farm I knew
absolutely nothing was thrown on as a
commissioner so again under the guidance
of Nikki and Cliff and David puller we
got through I think we lost about 12
months of Our Lives during that process
and that would never happen again
councilors considering a consent of that
magnitude but again that was cliff and
Nicki that did the hard work I was just
the year around making excuses why it
wasn't passing my exams but um look
we've worked together for a long time we
often disagreed but we remained friends
and you know that says a lot about this
Council and you know the leadership that
you you sit for people that join
so I wish you all the very best thank
you and it's cliche but you can leave
knowing you did make a difference
absolutely you're here
um any other comments before we
begin the meeting it's
the reality okay look we might go back
to the start
um
and we have one apology we have
councilor Nick Grant who's not able to
be with us today so would somebody like
to move that that be sustained
councilor Phillips secondary Council
MacDonald all those in favor please say
aye against the motion is carried thank
you
conflicts of interest are there any
conflicts that need to be declared at
this particular time from councilors
there's not in queue
um right we do have one item of Putin
late business that has been notified
and I'm going to raise that now with
counselors permission we have a
presentation or some individuals that
are going to present to us a copy of a
slideshow that you will have received on
your on your Hub with regarding
revaluation of the district
property assets
so would somebody like to move that we
accept this particular piece of urgent
information and I agree to have it heard
now
so move counselor grad seconded
counselor Davis thank you all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried so look
welcome along to quotable value we have
Tim Gibson and I'm
in Harvey in the room with us and they
have a slideshow that they're going to
present to us they've just completed the
valuation of the district makes
interesting reading and it'll be good to
get a perspective on what that looks
like from their their view so look Tim
hey Ben if you want to come forward
and uh
I'm not sure where we where would you
like to present from
cool thanks uh you worship and
councilors so I'm sorry to drag you back
into into business
but
um so we have just undertaken the um
three yearly revaluation or rating
values for school district
um so these got implemented
um on Friday approved from the Auditors
um so it gives a good opportunity to
come in and um
discuss and present you the results of
the revaluation so um
for uh come up
thank you
um so we'll just run through the um the
process that we go through for the um
the revaluation obviously the results
where the values have gone key dates
um that's important for the public
um that includes objection dates and
we'll go across there as we get to it
and obviously open it to the floor for
any questions
so the um the rating valuations are held
under the rating valuations 1998
um the thing to remember about them is
it's not just a um
a three-year cycle and between the three
years if he's building consent activity
um subdivision activity new titles we're
continuously updating the um the rate
evaluation with that building consent
new titles subdivisions uh whatever the
change may be so we get notified of all
consents from garages through to new
homes which once are built we update the
um the DVR or the rating valuation
um over that three years and between the
uh the revaluations so when the the
values get renewed
um they're as accurate as possible as
you know given that this 6500 properties
roughly in Gold District
um so the process around the revaluation
as we start off with the market analysis
so we're looking out at what's happening
in the market what's changed in the
three years
um big one for Gore is obviously
District plan just in this stage of
um
publicized new District clean and the
spatial plan that come out prior to it
so a lot of that was a
what a specially the spatial plan was
public information that had been out
there for a couple of years so that was
sort of giving an indication to the
public where zones may change
um and you know we're we're looking at
that and what the
um
the market evidence was showing when we
adopted our new values
um so we're looking at changes we're
looking at where to sell levels are
folding
um
any listings that are coming onto the
market uh we'll go across that in a
minute with the residential side
um so yeah it's it's a three-year change
really or snapshot of change
um so we hold individual worksheets hold
a commercial and Rural properties
um and we also undertake the residential
side of fear high percentage of roadside
inspections so we're looking out for
things here that aren't captured on your
building because the consent changes so
you're looking at innocent from
maintenance
painting new roofs anything like that so
we just make making sure that the values
align to what what's on select
um so we go through a three week audit
period as well so um the office of the
original uh Department of lens will have
the property files uh conduct a two-day
on-site order and
really just grilled down into what's
happening they can observe in the market
that we've captured that those changes
and so it just gives more Assurance to
um the customers out there that their
rating value is a good represent
representation of a revaluation date
um is alluded to their rating values are
a snapshot of time
um so Gore is first of all July to uh
2022.
um they do not include chattels or tree
value
um
rating values uh are at that date for
three years so for Market changes
significantly and you know over the next
year and a half you always get a
um a period of values being well above
or well below the rating valuation
um yeah another idea as well
um we don't set the values
um we're interpreting of what the market
is so that's reflective of a three year
change
the big over overall results
um
so you can see there's been some pretty
high percentage changes here uh
throughout the um the categories
um one thing to point out is your other
categories are like your churches and
halls and schools that sort of don't
fall within your main subcategories here
um so the highest percentage obviously
residential and that's been very well
publicized over the um the media over
the last sort of year and a half two
years what's have been happening in the
residential side of things
um so yeah lifestyle as well following
that residential Trend commercial
industrial going really well especially
in your land and Industrial
and your lowest percentage here is your
rural component
and that's just showing us the same data
percentage movement and bar graph so
um your industrial lands has been driven
by
coming off quite a low value base and a
lot of vets land in southern Gore
we really had to increase what at a high
percentage around Faulkner Road
um there's a there's a block there
that's um is driving that really high
percentage
um a bit of both a bit of both it has
coming off a low value base and now
we're sitting at about 120 550 a square
meter for a industrial land
it is it's still pretty cheap so yeah
um just showing your percentage makeup
um and total value
um obviously your highest biggest jump
nearer is your um your rural properties
Dairy and pastoral and uh residential 33
percent
the same game of vanilla your land
sector it's more dominant even now in
your in your rural sectors so that you
know that's something to consider when
it comes through next year if you're um
striking rates
um on the residential this is our price
index that we hold
um the black line being the last
revaluation 2019.
and you can see
um
post covered things started to
um Kick along quite strongly and once we
got to 2021 it was just all go
um so we peaked sort of just after uh
January 2022
and um we're now sort of sliding back
the Market's calling a bit out there and
isn't the sales activities
down on the residential side
um and then that's been chance we're
hearing your value levels so we're here
to be careful where we pitched our
values as at the first of July that we
weren't pitching them as at January 2022
and that that come back to the audit
period
um so the Auditors were really focused
on have we hit the mark for uh July 2022
which is the revaluation date
is it great for showing
um yeah significant growth over 2021 and
and that's that was New Zealand white so
it's not just a Gore District or
Southland
um area
um yeah and calling in 2022 the low end
is where you're seeing the highest
percentage growth
um so material
um your wheat sediments waikaka pokerail
uh Esco
um are showing a higher percentage in
value growth
and that's showing that there
um you land in the tower may look quite
dramatic but we're probably sitting at
about 50 55 000 for a section in
material
um and yeah fairly steady growth and
your Capital values right throughout
um once you take the tower out of it
and your average values so Gore's
sitting there at about 4 30 uh yeah go
rural
um that includes your waikaka pukarau
mandevilles uh Mater what's it here
about two 275 280 average
uh so your business business properties
so when we undertake the um the
commercial industrial
um we send out questionnaires to owners
asking for rental information
um some you may have seen these float
around the district over the last sort
of three months
um so we're looking at the commercial
properties on an income and a yield
approach
um typically that's how these properties
are going to sell on the market so what
are the rents doing what are yields
doing
um factor in your land value component
and that and that's how we build up the
values so we've been seeing reasonable
rent growth of Angora the CBD retail was
you know steady
industrial has been the big mover and
that again is a trend that we're seeing
right around New Zealand industrial
moving at a higher rate than commercial
scene favorably by investors
so yields something that's low risk
when I when I say no risk it's good
modern building good location be around
about 7.25 seven and a half percent
um whereas something that's a wee that's
sort of
um strengthening requirements to the
building
um you can be in excess of 10 of those
type of buildings
there's a bit going on in this graph
um that Google rural real high bar there
is demonstrating The Fault in the road
industrial land that blocked there that
got changed and that's probably the
biggest change in the whole district is
that
that block of land really had to be
ramped up
yeah and then just fitty and thus um
then they use the material very
consistent with the residential
and then the rest is sort of just just
fairly standard steady
I'll hand over to Ian he'll take you
through to the real component next turn
okay smallest number of Assessments but
hugely important for the success of the
economy of war and really contribute a
lot to the total value
uh since 2019 the market was probably in
the rural
side was really static uh probably
started to lift late 2020 early Twenty
One reason being Dairy commodity prices
sort of increased to 950 meat prices
were strong and pastoral and also
forestry influence on lower lower valued
land suitable forestry so strong
interest in that area
um you know the smaller pastoral units
um yeah strong demand that more aligned
to the lifestyle so that's had probably
a bigger increase in the larger pastoral
units
increase the demand for landscendable
for conversion forestry and lifestyle
Lifestyles can range from anywhere from
1 to 20 hectares the bulk we'd like to
think around that four hectares and they
are more aligned to the residential so
they've shown a bigger increase than
the strictly royal properties
so it sort of mirrors a trend in other
districts Southland and the joining
clutha
why Matt is just been done and that was
probably a similar lift with steering
and pastoral
uh there we go there that's a during 12
and a half percent lift
that these are sort of averages too so
individual properties could vary
slightly so probably some of the better
units good infrastructure good
production could have a bigger lift than
12 and a half but that's these are
average figures don't forget
and the same with pastoral
some of those smaller pasture units
would have a bigger lift than the larger
pasture units
Horticulture only got one and that's
aligned to the
to the lifestyle
and
a handful of Mining and lifestyle big
increase aligned to the residential lift
happy to take questions
look
John
just down the air number assets this
number of this it's turned over in the
last three years or
is that the total number of assets on
the books
yeah that's the assessment number yeah
see I'm trying to work out how you get
the increase in mining at 25.7 how many
assets have we gotten yeah it was mining
will be there's probably a few quarries
around them
fairly precise isn't it yeah
um
so is the information available now for
individual Property Owners is there a
portal they can go and have a look
before they get notices
yeah we've supplied the five to order
from Council and
page next week sorry
minutes through school district council
this week and for um you know all that
online stuff like houses homes
a couple key key dates
um so the revaluation is effective first
of July
owners notices are going to be posted
from the 28th of September
application period so I can for I think
it's a six week period so once
objections close
um we'll start I'm speaking the
objections and um you know learning and
that reflect sales and facility
and obviously the um they use for rating
purposes come first of July 2033.
new questions
thank you Tim and Ian it's really good
to get a bit of an insight into what's
happening at a very in a very timely
juncture
um
I think
we might have just about covered the
questions have we is there any any other
questions that anybody has that's
pressing if not thank you for taking the
time to be here certainly appreciate it
and and appreciate the the work that's
gone in behind the scenes to get to this
point
and and I guess probably one of the
first challenges this Council will have
to deal with is what is the new rating
valuations look like when it comes to
setting rates in 2023 okay
thank you
okay um thank you councilors we'll move
back to the um
to the agenda
um and we're on to confirmation of
minutes so would somebody like to move
the confirmation of the minutes the
ordinary meeting of council held Tuesday
16 August
as a true and correct record councilor
Dixon dog secondary before that
uh Council Reed thank you is there any
alteration required to that record
does not I'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye against the
motion is carried thank you uh
confirmation of minutes of the
community's strategy committee held
Wednesday 24 August some would like to
move they'd be seen as a true and
correct record councilman fail to have a
seconder for that councilor Dixon thank
you any alterations required to that
report councilor
um
Grant
thank you you worship no alteration but
just to comment about uh
I was I wasn't available for that
meeting but there was in the report it's
uh
it was saying that some retailers were
disappointed that go retail had faded
away go retail hadn't failed a rainco
retail
um
was basically made up of three retailers
that are not there anymore that were
doing most of the donkey work
it was still around and um
and councilor Bronwyn Reed will will
know more about this as well there was a
meeting the other night that was held
and it's a it was a Revival of garito
they've actually looked at moving away
from that and the name is looking like
it's going to be good business support
network
um it was a teen of about 22 people uh
it's it's very strong looks like um and
there's some new blood in there and it's
going to be great so that was just
further comment on it okay but thank you
Doug that's good it's good to get that
news and um yeah I hear there is some
energy
um starting to flow through that group
which is um wonderful okay so is there
any odorations required to the record
this is not uh would somebody like to
move that any recommendations contained
within that report be adopted
counselor a high state to have a
signature
we did the confirmation of the
recommendations
okay secondary Council mcfarl
um
is there any discussion councilor hosted
yep
you're just the um I know the review of
80 year old parking program over 80 and
and the opportunity to um
to work with invercargill to encourage
those residents to
to be offered the parking permits and
Gore and vice versa I think a great
opportunity to offer the Macau residence
the opportunity to park and Gore and use
our retail and I think we should think
wider anyone over 80 and a catchment
should be encouraged to have free
parking and Gore in in a Avail
themselves of of the retail yeah
totally agree
um
not there yet getting close
okay
um no other
um comments from Council I'll put the
emotional loads in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councilors
right we'll move on to confirmation of
the minutes of the capital Works
committee held on Wednesday 31 August
that was something about to move that'd
be seeing this true and correct
councilor Bulger signature councilor
Phillips any alterations required to
that record
does not put that motion all those in
favor please say aye against the motion
is carried thank you councilors we've
done item four
uh and we have a presentation now and
um it's going to be by Zoom from um John
bazette or visit who is the acting area
commander for police just to talk us
through some new strategy that is being
adopted at the present time so hopefully
we can get them on Zoom
and
we'll be all guys
they've been waiting patiently good on
recording in progress
[Music]
hello John
sorry to keep sorry to keep sorry to
keep you waiting
um so welcome along
um and we're can you hear me okay
yeah we're just Keen to um to hear what
you've got to share with us with regard
to the the new initiative and and
perhaps any other issues that you want
to raise at this particular time so the
floor is yours John
yes you have
yep
but feel free if there's any questions
so
starting to work full place of Spain the
combination over a couple of years
um with you shooting at Auckland in 2020
and it was following their feet there
was quite a significant public
around
the general Island level the general
safety of the police
um we remember other issues in the
global climate around the time around
um
protests and a number of other things so
New Zealand Police found quite a
significant official work
um
that environment in terms of what's the
best options in terms of
keeping police members safely which
fundamentally has a role on people
around kicking down
the wrong sort of trial through
development sorry
the technical response model is all
about uh
same goal effect around the community
safety
um
starting this largely around making sure
our staff were trying to equipped and
Peter garpia in terms of keeping himself
safe
but based on that I'll be significant
piece of work that we did around
understanding the environment and what
were the best options New Zealand places
at this stage the remaining of generally
Amazon
it doesn't change that at all
just based on
really good
kind of study and all the evidence it
sets around them and also based on the
community feedback and on that concept
so
over the past few years at broadened to
um
a model being trials and it's currently
being trial in four different districts
around the country
um all of which are in the North Island
which we call approval concept districts
um
foundation so this has gone in
a
nutshell
this is where if anyone has any
questions please entertain
Ed but this is the proposed model now in
sort of what the next steps are but
um the Crucial Conflict trials have been
running for the past
um
eight or nine months across those
and it's been required
and this is the
um the refined model which is currently
being a valuable
so it kind of works a full main work
strings remembering that the larger
routines is around remaining generally
unarmed
um but trying to get that really upburst
and trying to
changes the first piece of it and the
top left corner is around training and a
really short seems a bit to increase for
all Frontline staff
for 3.5 days up to seven days per annum
foreign
appreciate University assistance all
that
Focus
that is probably the biggest
safety is that really it's a significant
piece to work for place right across the
business it is probably the biggest
thing that the front by offices will
feel and that nest of us and training
uh second point is around
it is good to get a real clear heads up
on what the direction you're going in I
guess a question I had is so so when are
we likely to see this starting to roll
out and across the country
so
at this stove
this is just a bit of an engagement so
how we design the model was based off
of the evidence that we studied
as well as they did significant work
around gay technique which is the large
piece around
our schedules
as well
and that's how they formulated the model
with a 1200 staff involved in the design
of it um vehicles and impact trying to
get that boys from their rural staff as
well as the Metro areas
um so this is going to be we're setting
them in the next door belong to your
question
um so we're currently underground
approval evaluation so they're giving us
both in the center as conducting an
apparent evaluation of the approval
contact District that are
brains
um based on that final model will make a
proposal to the 36 each level around
what the final recommendation is largely
we
valuation
um
the thing for the crucial concept has
been really positive from our staff
around the way that felt a lot
um a lot safer and
one of the things that really as
valuable was that training so Southern
districts are here in Southland we have
already started the uplift and that
Frontline safety training we
is such a valuable place so we've
already started doing that
um
and this this photo answer your question
so
um based on that final evaluation
um recommendation will obviously made to
the Police Executive there is some
funding applications in terms of central
government
and the police funding that supports
this
So based on that final evaluation uh net
funding
um this engagement if there's any
feedback all that will be sort of
culminated in what is the form of
recommendation so for anticipating
evaluation to be completed in October
and we're anticipating an announcement
in terms of the final model before the
end of the year
great and look thanks John
um I guess just another question I have
is in terms of
um human resources to to cover some of
the the different methods that you're
using and you're talking about dog teams
uh now as opposed to single Dog Handlers
and also
um 24 7. um
operations control in Dunedin to is this
going to put any pressure on Frontline
staff that we see out and about now
um so the final model will be proposed
to the executive
this is part of the discussion around
the funding networks secured for police
it was an output central government
about Chris
um the 10th responsible was part of it
so
once we made the final recommendation
potentially depending on their funding
we may receive some additional resources
to support
the actualist report so East is
built-ins will require additional
Staffing and the DC is safe
they won't come the
thing from our current front line it
will be um
thank you
um okay councilors any questions or
comments from them thank you worship
um
given that your program is Frontline
safety does that include the mental and
emotional well-being of your staff and
is there any if that I presume it does
but is there an uplift in the amount of
professional help that they can access I
mean given some of the situations
they're in I'm sure they're
find themselves
wondering sometimes what's happening
yep
the Online safety program the the
technical response to the model is is
separate from the Facebook talking about
Wellness services so
we have a really uh good and very fast
system and internally that our staff can
access
um it has a number of services so we
haven't did have it Wellness officer for
southern
and there's a whole lot of services that
all our staff practice
available in
any insight they want basically we have
an online platform that this afternoon
we have an online platform that family
and um water whom I can access
I think what we've done a lot of work in
the space over the last few years I
think our Wellness services
they might be a kind of exceptionally
thanks John
Richard
yes um thanks for that inspector
um just a couple of questions in regard
to obviously from the community point of
view
um do we have resources local once it's
all done is there any concerns that
um we haven't got enough on the street
at the moment are we satisfied with what
we've got out there and uh obviously
with the localized training that's going
to occur does that go through from a
national level if they agree on this and
come down and are they trained locally
to actually enhance the street policing
down here for our community
um so the train is China is actually
confronted in front of our training will
be uh that we're really confident it'll
be in the final model so we'll see that
has provided us for four week extra
positions in Southland to provide that
training so
they are four of our current AOS
operators who train Four Frontline staff
within um
eventually implies
because we're really confident that's
going to be in the final models
okay and just
in regards that you obviously just what
we've got you here we've obviously got
enough resources within the southern
community at the moment like Southland
community on the street
we are
um and
it's always a question for us to write
around how do we use that how is it most
effective
um
we have
three years from the government's um
additional place today
additional
across South and
quite a bit of
additional resource you know there's
always that question that we're talking
about had more but as promised there's
always a question around how do we use
I think we're in a relatively good
position at the moment
no thank you speaker keep up with good
work
thank you John
um and I guess I'm not sure there's any
other questions around the council table
but yeah it's a while since we've had a
senior police presence at the council
meeting so really good to have you here
and I just wonder is there any thoughts
or um any information you'd like to
share with us around policing in eastern
at this particular time you know how is
it going are we um we're in the right
direction are there are there areas that
we as a as a council need to be aware of
um
kind of that whole social well-being
space is is something that we're really
Keen to lean into in order to encourage
any community group Council early to
invest in that
but we will always do our part in terms
of
working really hard to
um
to address the people that need address
for us but there's a there's one
Association of the real challenge you
know um
we're working really hard
to
address
but again it's it's a real challenge
it's
as homosexual leadership that drives
um addiction
uh as much as we've been filming so it's
kind of a real balance for us
but there would be this nice social
well-being
thanks John
um well I think I don't think there's
any other questions or comments from
counselors but
um look I really do appreciate your time
coming along today it's good to get an
insight into what's uh what's on the
horizon and and good to stay connected
so um all the best and thanks again for
being here
okay thank you
on the last page but there is a email
address
tonight that email addresses is the
mechanism by which a feedback so if
anyone has any ideas or thoughts
um
great thank you John
okay
um okay
um we'll move on then to item six
which is issuing of Staff warrant and
authorization and this reasonably
straightforward is there any comment
there that you want to make Steve yeah
um
right open for discussion counselors and
the recommendation is that it be
received
moved and seconded councilor Davis thank
you
right uh we'll move on then to
where am I oh you're sorry always in
favor yeah
yeah I lost the plot
right
um I'm on here
thank you counselors uh item seven
um cat management and control
subcommittee quarterly update
um and we have a report here from our
air consultant and we have a number of
the members of that particular working
group with us today that look reads
pretty well and looks like there's some
good stuff
being worked through but is there any
comment any of those members would like
to make before I open it up to the wider
Council
please
[Music]
shoes and having issues with cats and
there are other community people that
are really Keen to join the group that
we've had to turn some of them away of
course but there seems to be a an awful
lot of interest in what we're doing and
and from not just in war but outside of
the district as well
okay
that's certainly good to see that there
is interest and
and there's definitely a challenge
there's no doubt about that
okay I would like to move that report be
received
councilor MacDonald signal for that
councilor Garden uh any comment
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councilors
uh item eight and we have the minutes of
the Matera community board meeting held
on 12 September which is pretty recent
uh and
do you want to make any comment to that
Steve
no no okay
um I guess Neville is a representative
on there do you want to make any
comments before I open it up to
counselors
um
I don't think it's anything needs to be
committed on at the moment you worship
only the factors that uh
they're welcome
to material signs or the material signs
hopefully they'll be out before
Christmas
um
it's good to see that the uh the molds
are getting made now so and that the
engineer came back with the satisfactory
ground support so those foundations
shall be going in shortly
I look forward to seeing them up
and the only uh other issue of course is
uh
it's the last recommendation on the or
item number five about the
Queen's pack
uh happy to take any questions from any
councilors at the moment
okay so the items open for discussion
any questions uh comments Council Dixon
worship just a question for new
um just reading through this it said
that the white were
went from the tower to gore for chipping
which
um don't think that that would be
correct whether it was
wood that was taken to call for chipping
or white Weir to be disposed or
perhaps um you worship Mr Newmar and
what we have to answer that question
just thank you councilman sure you
worship the
um discussion at the material community
board were on that was on the basis that
the whiteware ETC that is sitting down
at material at this point it hasn't been
shifted yet but it will be brought up to
gore where it will be chipped at Bond
Contracting cost
and we've got a Tripper on site just
doing green waste at the moment but
possibly next week he'll start chipping
the
scrap metal and they have already done
through Tiana longstone
Etc and other South and District Council
areas and all the cost is going back to
bond is it's the responsibility to look
after the metal
another question
um for Neville was or just a review of
the amount that's paid to the um
the club for the work that they do at
the transfer station that seems to be
a very low fee that they're charging 70
dollars for five hours are they happy
with that or
thank you
yeah
um you worship look they at the
community War meeting we had
representation from
the Bowling Club and it may not be known
as that the Bonnet club actually
physically look after the landfill site
on a Sunday afternoon from one o'clock
to four o'clock
they have a rotational system and
they get the minimal payment from
the council for doing so
um
they've done it for a number of years
and currently we're just asking for
uh for it to be reviewed and we did say
that um
that with the review coming up of all
landfills including Gore and the waste
minimization at the moment that that
could be part of the review and also the
structure of the material transfer
station in its capacity at the moment so
they were more than happy with that at
the moment so once we do that it's part
of the review I think we'll um will be
satisfied and there is a few other
questions now in regards to is it
appropriate for them to do it and so on
and so on so yeah that's uh we'll be
part of that discussion
yeah and look I think that that does
bring up the issue of waste management
and uh in Matera and I think that it
neatly fits into the rethinking waste
that we're as a council proposing and
the next term will be right off the top
of the agenda so I'm sure that those
issues will be dealt with at that
particular time
um Doug thanks Josie um
item five on that agenda merging of
sections in the Queen's part
um I I see there's board members here
requested that we do that the council
arranged for the properties to to be
incorporated and it's also been seconded
as well
um
but then uh with all the
Avenues exhausted and the respect of
relocating the siding the railway
station
and which again is being
it's the item on the next agenda as well
should we leave that decision of this
item number five over to the next or do
we
discuss that now because to me
um
should we be putting two derelict houses
in the Queen's part right now
because something's going to have to be
done with them obviously there are now
owned by the council because we
purchased them for the idea of
relocating but
am I putting the horse before the cat or
any thoughts
so just that so we're all aware the
sites we're talking about one's empty is
it one one's clear and one has got a
house on it that is inhabited
it's not inhabited okay okay so yeah one
one needs to be cleared and one is is
fine
counselor hosted yeah I agree with
Council grandliners on there she has I
had it written down as well like
ultimately a marriage name of the
Queen's pack seemed a good idea but it
seems premature like that's putting the
reserve status on the sites before
they're incorporated into the park
surely we would pause
see what the use of the sites are and at
that time version because a future
committee board may decide to realize
those assets and then put the money into
something else that's far far greater
for the material communities so once you
put Reserve status on a site as I
understand it pretty hard to unwind so
why don't we keep our options open for
the community board it's the decision I
realize that and I respect that but
tying their hands are probably
interested in some feedback from the
chief executive
but it would tie the hands up I
understand
Steve do you want to make any comments
uh you thanks you worship
um you look
this is not a
five minute process and therefore not
just the issue around what the council
may decide at the next item on the
agenda but also in the acknowledgment
that the majority of the current board
members are not standing for a
re-election it could well be that you
may wish to hold that recommendation in
advance and present it to the new board
for either adoption or otherwise
and you'll only lose a month or so and
if a new board were of a similar mind to
the current board then you can proceed
with
incorporating it into Queen's Park if
not
um then as you said you can then be free
to
to sell those assets uh if if on the
assumption that material station doesn't
go ahead so
um on balance I don't think you lose too
much if you hold it in advance if that's
your wish and present it to the new
board for consideration amongst uh
okay so cliff
yeah so can I move that we do that
exactly what
yeah okay so you're moving in the
direction that the chip executive has
just explained correct can I just
explained you worship that I
recommendation or my suggestion uh was
that that's held in advance not rejected
so it's important to say that the board
hasn't been rejected it's been held in
advance for consideration by the new
board
okay so
um so we've got one chain is is there
any disagreement with that process
no okay
anything else in the community board
minutes that we need to address at this
particular time
Council Phillips
uh you also I'd just like to
um put on recorder and express my thanks
to the outgoing community board uh for
their Sterling work that they've shown
in material in the last uh somewhere
I've done more than one term but um
especially the chairman of the community
board he's done a sterling work over the
last period of time that he's been on
the on
and I wish them all their best in their
retirement and I look forward to working
with the new community board whatever
makeup it may be
and maybe a bit of a challenge but I've
always liked challenges
thank you
good on you and I endorse the comments
that that Neville has made and and I
know that
look the community board have had its
ups and downs over the years from its
formation
and I'd have to say that in the last
three terms anyway
it may be in the last four terms that
community board has shown more foresight
and drive than ever before and it's it's
really good to see and that they do need
to be acknowledged for that and I don't
think there's any further community
board meetings before the election but
we do need to make an effort as a
council in some way shape or form in
recognizing the members for the
contribution they have made today
because it has been significant and and
and a lot of that they don't get a huge
remuneration for the work that they do
okay other points from the
agenda would somebody like with that
um one alteration to the recommendation
that was moved by councilor Grant
are we happy to Second those minutes
Council Reed
uh all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right that brings us to
um the next item which has got a direct
correlation
and it relates to the Matera railway
station future
and
we have a report from the chief
executive which is quite far-reaching
and and reasonably decisive in the
recommendations that have been
drawn at the at the end of it so Steve
I'll pass this on to you before I open
it up for the council consideration
thanks you worship
I was away at the July council meeting
when the council considered the
feasibility study for the mattar railway
station building which was sought by the
community board to help navigate its
future Direction on this project and as
a consequence of that consideration of
that item I was asked to do a report
about the future of the project in
totality
um
I've worked my way through this and I
guess I came to the conclusion that
the project
was getting away from all of us in terms
of the uncertainty of cost
and also uncertainty around the proposed
use
you'll note that I actually wrote the
report in its first initial basis on the
31st of August and it was only when the
community board met on the just last
Monday that I inserted
the final paragraph six which should be
6.6 the foot of my report
and in the process of doing so changed
my recommendation my recommendation
initially was that to invite the council
to articulate a provisional view about
the Project's viability and then refer
that to the new community board for
consideration but with the community
boards to Liberation on the uh just last
Monday I then thought well I think that
board has come to the realization that
it's just too difficult to see it being
advanced in a timely way and so I have
changed my recommendation that I believe
the council needs to blow the whistle
and come to terms of the fact that the
project at this point in time is
just a daunting challenge with no
um meaningful or significant funding
sources that were able to be
secured and have the project advanced in
a timely way
um
and
whether the new board has a different
view I'm not I'm obviously around
certain but I felt out of respect for
the outgoing board to a champion the
project if they've come to the
conclusion that I had pretty much
we should put the recommendation and
provide some certainty the other flip
side of the corners kiwi rail do want to
know what's going on with the the future
of that building or be it that it has
over many years decided to not maintain
it
and it will be
sad to see the the building
um
potentially being removed or demolished
maybe but who knows that this may be a
trigger point for qrail to revisit it
starts from the building given its
historic Heritage the other point I made
mention of my report and it's something
that just really dawned on me as as I
was writing it is that
uh here we have a
significant corporate entity uh owning a
building and the the rate payers and the
collective resources are trying to
Marshal funds to
um restore and relocate that building
and is that something that we would do
with another Heritage building that
might be owned by a a private entity
and that that I guess trouble troubled
me somewhat in terms of what potentially
the council could face down the line as
other buildings May potentially fall
into various states of disrepeare so
it's been a long-running project your
worship and I think the project like
others have been the victim of covert
rampant inflation when it comes to
construction
uncertainty about any renovation project
that provides a high degree of
uncertainty
and then coupled with the um uncertainty
around proposed use all to me pointed
towards the project not being viable at
this point in time
thanks Steve okay so look I feel the
full some summary there and a request
for this particular Council to make some
directions now on that particular issue
so book goods open for discussion
councilors and I look forward to um
be sharing your views
Council Bossier
thanks for the report Steve it's
a sad fact that it is
identified and Report not viable to
secure the Old Railway Station and
relocate it and that's
a shame and that opportunity won't exist
again
but when you consider this a million
dollars involved potentially and no
other funders
really we don't have a lot of choice no
doubt about it the community board made
every effort to preserve what I consider
an iconic structure for material to
retain it but um
I agree with the report that it's
financially anyway
we're better to walk away from it and
allow kiwi rail to
remove it
and I've appeared to move the
recommendation
okay thank you Cliff um so we have
recommendation does to have a second for
that oh second it secretary Council
Davis thank you I just want to say that
it's
I really commend the material Community
brought on doing everything they could
and their power to make this happen
and it's just come to a point that it's
just not viable unfortunately and I just
think that kiwi rail really
have a bit of a cheek expecting the
community to pick up the pieces for a
building that they own an historic
building no less that they own and
they've let it go to where it can ruin
and I think that's disgraceful and I
really really commend the material
committee award on trying their level
best
um but it's all going the wrong way so
as a as a council I don't see how we can
support any further work on this one so
thank you thank you Nikki okay uh
councilors up open we have a
recommendation that's been been moved
and seconded
any other comments from counselors
uh councilor Phillips
thank you your worship
I'm not really sure what to say about
this really but
you know I'm extremely disappointed at
the board and this Council weren't
able to get together and save the Matera
railway station the only one in
existence in New Zealand
and for us to say that was because it's
uh in the two hard basket you know like
once again I I feel disappointed
I I feel disappointed that we weren't we
weren't able to work together as a
council and a board to achieve the
outcome and the outcome was that we save
an iconic building
of New Zealand listed Heritage 2
building
I know the board I know the board
itself is extremely disappointed with
the decision it had to make on on Monday
but it was all about
effect was that it didn't have any
backup it never got any backup from
Council now every one of those
counselors have your own decision to
make about what you should do with the
building
but it's about what it was
you know it was about history
in the making
for the district
and
I'm extremely disappointed that it's got
to the stage
but if this Council
or this year of 2022 decide that is to
go back to Kiwi Rail and it gets pulled
down
then my vote was recorded as a no
that we should do everything we possibly
can to keep it in their District
thanks
thank you councilor Phillips look I I
take the points that you're making and
and absolutely I'm as passionate about
the Matera railway station as anybody is
um I've lived with it for 50 years of my
life in my view I've worked on it I've
been on the on the platform
a lot longer than I ever wanted to be
it's got a lot of personal history to me
but I do take point with the issue the
arrays about the council and the
community board not working together I I
believe the community board and the
council have worked together on this one
certainly it hasn't been easy and it
does come back to to funding
and and if you can see any particular
Avenue where that funding might come
from uh in in reasonably short order
then I think we need to hear it because
that really is the that's the sticking
point at this point in time I don't
think there's anybody around the table
wouldn't like to see that restored and
put to put to good use
but we as a council need to be prudent
about how we
make their decisions
nibble
do you worship if you're really really
passionate about giving up that you've
been involved with for 50 years you will
vote and know with me but what I'm
saying here is that there was supposed
to be a working party that was set
around this Council table to make this
decision about come back with some
information
we asked as a community board
for
photos
a projected photograph of what it might
look in the located site so we could
push it out it never happened and so and
so I can keep going on and on but
just about five minutes ago this Council
decided that they weren't going to
put the land that the community board
were going to put the railway site
station on and do Reserve if you read
back on the minutes about why the last
community board want to put into Reserve
but the simple fact is that the new
community board that may come come in
whoever they may be may be able to sell
that land and it will not become a green
space
on the recommendation now that's the
reason why they wanted to do that way
but
Hester will tell what happens
and look I I think the vet Avenues are
there it's just that we need to get a
decent working body together to get this
thing up and running
okay so we have a recommendation uh are
there any other comments from counselors
around the table
is not
uh I'm going to put the motion that's on
the table
all those in favor please say hi
against the motion is carried
and and I'm not happy about that at all
but I recognize the situation that we
find ourselves in
and if anybody and that I'm speaking to
a wider public I guess in this
particular instance if anybody has any
viable view in their mind of how that
might progress then they need to let us
know pretty darn quick because I don't
think there's anybody in their heart of
hearts around this table actually wants
to see it demolished I think people want
to see that restored and put to a good
purpose but
we are in a corner
okay
um
you're worship we're not sitting here
today with demolition in front of us
let's go here's his status it's got a
close location and it's got an owner
so I I think it's a little bit Rich to
be saying that you know council is
trying to forward for demolition now the
owner has to take responsibility and
deal with Heritage status by growth here
if anyone's got a solution we'd love to
hear
and I guess I I'm I cast those comments
in my um
my dealings with kiwirail in this
particular issue has been fraught to say
the least look there might be a change
apart and
with his life there's hope so um we'll
wait and see
okay
I don't think there is hope because as
from this week
someone had boarded up all the windows
in the building and it's only been the
decision from the community board on
Monday and by Tuesday the boards were
all boarded up around the window so
hearing always asks the question
if you go down to matara now or you're
gonna or you see for that railway
station that's not the windows but
plywood so
okay
[Music]
um
let's move on Council
um we'll move on then to minutes of
rural halls and domains some Grant
subcommittee which was held recently we
have some recommendations somebody like
to move the receipt of those of the the
minutes and move the recommendations
with Council MacDonald signal councilor
mcphail is there any comment on those
recommendations
it is not of what the motion all those
in favor please say aye against the
motion is carried thank you
right I think that brings us to the end
of our open Agenda business oh sorry
where are we
ah right I've got an old agenda right
okay
so we're no I haven't got it online
yeah
okay
um so item 11 Roe Esplanade pedestrian
cycle Crossing and quite an exciting
project
we have a report here from the roading
asset manager
and I would ask Murray if you want to
lead us through that
yeah
three three Winship
um yes the um this project is a project
that uh has been
um on the box uh for
at least a year or over a year
um it's a project uh that consists of
two components one is to provide a safer
Crossing of Royal East Bernard for
pedestrians and and cyclists and the
other other component of is to provide a
safer
um
crossing of the main South
rail Crossing as a railway line
so the project is actually fully funded
by
um waka katahi ncta they from my
understanding instigated the the project
so they've provided a funding up to 120
000
which from my rough
costing of the whole project should
should be enough to to carry out the
whole whole of the project so that's the
crossing of both the the rowes blood and
which is obviously State i1 and and the
um the roller line
um so the the crossing of the rower line
is a requirement or the upgrading of
crossing of the crossing of the rail
line is a
a requirement from kiwi roll
um but they have
um
been reasonably
um easy on us they haven't required us
to uh to do some of the pretty elaborate
sort of um pedestrian Crossings over
Rover lines that they often do in these
situations
so that
if you go through the report there there
is
um uh talk a report on the
um
the safety
assessment of the Crossing on behalf of
kiwi roll and ourselves
which
confirmed that that what is proposed
will be
acceptable to Kiwi rail so yep
great okay so thank you Murray it's open
for discussion
handle comment um
thank you you worship
um it's very exciting I think it's great
I've been very keen to see this go ahead
too as I know councilor heisted and a
few others have attempted quite quickly
but my concern from the report is it
great we're going to get the cross and
all the rest of it but there seems to be
no mention of a speed limit reduction
coming down I mean that's going to be
this was it 70k you can't have a
pedestrian Crossing with a speed limit
like that so is there any
suggestion from nzta that they will
actually review that limit
through worship yes I um that there is
going to be a reduction in that area
anyway because
the section of stataway one or roast uh
that runs past the crossing is also very
close to the Esports school
and there's a requirement for a
reduction in the speed limits around
schools Across the Nation over the next
couple of years so the the maximum speed
limit that will result from that from
that change will be 60 kilometers an
hour however I had some discussion with
sorry I'll go back a step so there's two
categories of speed limit uh past
schools uh one the category a is down to
40 kilometers an hour that is where the
um the school gates at the main entrance
where the the children uh come into the
school
um uh and there's the category B is 60
kilometers an hour where uh there's sort
of a secondary entrance or a service
entrance into the school which is the
case a free score is called the other
thing I discussed with
um nzda our good day nzta this morning
was the possibility of Shifting the
um the speed limit uh well the the
transition to 100 kilometers an hour
further out as well um so um they're
looking very favorably at that as well
as a change or shifting of the
um 100K transition
um quite a bit further south at the
south end of town as well so there's
likely to be some pretty major changes
in the speed limit
um in the
reasonably close uh close future
thank you so when you say reasonably
close future I mean I know you haven't
got a crystal wall but would that be
prior to The Pedestrian axis being built
so that the public can get used to that
reduction in speed limit before people
start using it
um through worship uh that's something
that I need to confirm with them I think
the change to 60k is probably likely to
be able to happen reasonably quickly one
other point to note is that The
Pedestrian Crossing that we're talking
about isn't a zebra Crossing it's it's
basically
the construction of build out curve
curve on one side of the road on the the
west side of the road and
The Pedestrian refuge in the in the
middle of the road so The unliken
Pedestrian Crossing The Pedestrian
doesn't have have
um the priority there so
um the they they still have to take the
normal care that they they need to do
but it does give the prediction to the
cyclists and pedestrians if they do get
caught out in the Middle Road because it
is quite a wide sectional Road
so will there be markings on the road
that make it look like a pedestrian
Crossing
another true worship band no they won't
but there will be uh signage
um on the approaches to the um to the
crossing
um so
um yeah if we put
um
zebra markings there uh it has to go
through a warranting process
particularly being on a state highway
um and um it wouldn't with the the
volume of pedestrian cycle traffic that
uses it it wouldn't meet the
requirements for a zebra Crossing at the
moment there's also not the the built up
area on the on the east side of the the
road so the uh that pedestrian and cycle
traffic over there is relatively
intermittent it's not an all-day
um or even all week
um situation
hmm okay councilor hosted
he thinks here we're actually gave me an
awful fright there I've been waiting
three years for this item so thank you
for bringing that
um listen I totally support uh the first
part of the recommendation
um but I think learning from other
activities on streets we should have
more detail as a council here we had
submissions from the school and from
hokanu bikers on this and we need to
make sure it's going to be fit for
purpose for the school and for the
bikers I've already had concern from the
bikers that will will young children
feel safe and the more of that Highway
with their bike Crossing so
um really appreciate where we've got to
but it may need more support from the
council to become something that is that
is fit for purpose so I think we should
definitely support the recommendation I
don't like the second part because it's
open-ended it says that the council will
support contribute funding greater than
120 000 I don't think we'd we would
leave that open-ended so I think that
needs some work but definitely think
it does need to come back to council
with detail following engagement with
the school and how can I leave bikers
just to make sure we get
something that works so whether now I
should if anyone else wants to speak or
should we get on to the recommendation
Doug
been my new job of wandering around New
Zealand all over the place and driving a
large vehicle
I had this exact issue the other day in
um in the north island and I kind of
remember exactly where it was but it
wasn't a large town
probably double the size of
Gore
there might have been metamata I can't
remember where it was
anyway uh this this child was trying to
cross the road
on one of these exact Crossings this is
a courtesy Crossing correct
yes it's a courtesy Crossing there's no
marks on it so the kid was standing
there and it didn't know whether to go
so I I stopped the truck and we got a
big unit I stopped the truck
the little girl walked to the middle of
the road the traffic on the other side
kept going so I sat there we've got
flashing lights I put my flashing lights
on and I blasted the horn at this woman
and she looked at me like well what's
the problem
the courtesy Crossing and my mind is not
going to cut it
on a main road that's that's my first
issue I believe we should have markings
on the road and Tracy you you sort of
alluded to that there are no other
markers on the road just it's it looks
like an island right
I mean I don't know Murray I don't know
the volume that you have to tick to get
it to get a a pedestrian Crossing but we
shouldn't have to have a volume to
ticket if if we are demanding or looking
at a pedestrian Crossing we need a
pedestrian Crossing there so people can
safely do that the second issue is
the speeds
every town that you drive through some
of them have got they go from an 80 to a
50 some of them go from a 60 to a 30.
they're just diabolical and that's
nothing that we can do as this Council
but we should be pushing
a little bit more and say hang on a
minute we would like
why would you go to 60. we don't have a
60 now we go from 100 to 70 to 50. right
why on Earth would you Chuck a 60 in
there you're just going to confuse the
whole bloody issue you're better off
going a hundred
to 70 to 50.
or a hundred direct to 50. and and a lot
of these towns now have
200 meters away
they'll say
in 200 meters 50k zone right
it gives you time to look at it right so
by slowing them way down further out the
road and and I know this stretch road is
not under the air jurisdiction exactly
it's wagon could say because it's State
Highway number one yes that's great okay
it's not under our jurisdiction but as a
council this is our tip and these are
our people and these are our citizens
that are crossing those roads and these
are our children and our dogs and the
whole lot you know joggers in our
hokanui bikers we should be protecting
the backside off these people and saying
we don't you know we need to push back
as hard as possible
but I can't can't disagree with within
things being said and I guess I guess
the question now is now that we
understand uh what is proposed over
there what is the next step
um and I know Brit you talked about uh
endorsing the first part but not the
second part is that going to cut it at
this point in time do you think
yeah well unless we have a detail and
the budget how can we say we're going to
contribute funding to complete the
project should it be greater than 120k
um does that needed for what kotahi to
agitated
to progress is that the reason it's
there or
are we are we just up for whatever it
takes or the underpass seems like a good
option about now if that's the case
yep um so just if I could just go back a
step to answer some of the
um queries that councilor Grant made uh
just a couple of points there is the
speed limits that Council Grant was
referring to are no longer available
um so the the graduations and speed
limits are 80 60 and 40. so
um we're not going to get the 50 or 70
it currently is 70 but that will be
changing uh in the
um in the next couple of years
quite possibly two or 40. um
um so so um that that will address that
that issue
um the other thing to note is
um the suggestion that
um we
um
uh you know push for the uh pedestrian
it was a zebra Crossing there
um Council I should note that um in
Matera for instance
um by clutterbucks the FourSquare store
um there's a similar
um similar sort of situation with a
pedestrian refuse there's no zebra
Crossing there and there's quite a a
much greater volume of pedestrians use
that particularly Crossing then then the
crossing that's being proposed here and
one of the problems that
um will occur if we uh if we um if a
zebra Crossing is put in there with a
very low pedestrian and and cycle volume
crossinger is that
uh motorists going through it will never
see pedestrians and cyclists on it a lot
of the time and they become complacent
and just completely disregard The
Pedestrian Crossing anywhere those
people crossing anyway so we don't want
to undermine the placebo crossings that
have been put in in places that warrant
it so that's why at the
courtesy Crossing is more appropriate at
this stage if if that changes then we
can we can push Waka kotahi um and on
changes I'm talking about as a a
significant increase in the volume of of
users of the crossing and that that may
occur as a chicken and egg situation
maybe but at the moment there's just
far too few users
that will be used in The Crossing and
the upgrading it to a zebra Crossing is
is not as is going to be
counterproductive okay
so look I think
um everybody around the table wants this
to happen we just we want it to happen
in a safe way and and Murray said that
as if it doesn't meet the criteria for
zebra Crossing but we just need to
perhaps take stock here and think about
what are the options I know Steve's got
some sorts there do you want to share
those with us
you think she we should I just thought I
would um struggle out an amended
recommendation that might meet the mood
of the committee of the council
so suggested amendment is in the second
prong of the recommendation
that the court the council's support in
principle the construction of the active
mode Crossings
rather than support Implement support
and principle and then to replace the
third prong with and that the council
liaise with hakanu bikers and the escort
school to ensure all necessary
improvements to address Community needs
are incorporated into the final design
of the project
hmm
sorry
you could uh to ensure all Community
needs including safety
are incorporated into the final design
of the project
okay so we have a mover do I have a
signal for that councilor back to now
um right anything further any Council
wants to
mentioned at this point in time
counselor you've got on
it'll be interesting to watch the
numbers and actually use them now we can
get a count and then build a case
because basically if we kissed 120 000
goodbye at the moment in the business
case lapses and you'll find it doesn't
roll around for another year so I think
it's going to be a good thing to build
on hey
okay
um Murray
um yeah one thing to note is that there
has been a count of the numbers of
pedestrians and Cyprus that use the use
that or crossover in the vicinity of the
existing road crossing into Hamilton
Park and I think uh that I think that's
what in the report it was around about
118 I think for memory per day which is
a relatively no low number
um
that's right
yeah okay all right sorry Steve you just
you wish up the wealth and I should I
should say too is that in terms of what
if if there's uh other enhancements
sought by uh the school and the biking
community that take the project
outside the realm of a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars is likely uh I
can't say a guarantee that this project
May feature in the final list of the
better off
um three Waters first phase funding that
will be considered by this Council in
early October so just bear that in mind
but they say it's likely not it's not
probable but it could well feature in
the final list of that committee
we we have a motion and a secondary
councilman Farrell
just as an aside in the discussion
before we vote we currently have a
courtesy Crossing and a 70k area on the
south end of Gore which crosses from
Maple Grove across onto a footpath that
then goes into Salford street so if
we've got great concerns regarding the
safety of that we actually have one
existing in our neighborhood which I'm
sure you'll find that children cross
over going to Longford it accesses the
end of Broughton Street so
we probably want to have a look at that
too somewhere along the line there
okay
um good point I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye against
the motion is carried okay thank you
councilors
um right second attempt I think we've
come to the end of the open Agenda
and anything further we'll be discussed
in committee so with that in mind I will
move that the public be excluded from
the following parts of the proceedings
General subject of matter below
confirmation of minutes of a business
e-school Water Treatment Plant Wigan
Street Wastewater Library